many reactions of alkynes are similar to
those of alkenes so I recommend watching
our alkene video first let's begin with
a few alkyne forming reactions
the first method we'll examine is a
multi-step process called the Cori Fuchs
reaction an aldehyde is treated with a
mixture of carbon tetra bromide and
triphenylphosphine
CBR 4 reacts with triphenylphosphine to
form this organophosphorus compound or
vinegary agent which reacts with the
aldehyde to form a dye bromo alkene the
bromide is subsequently treated with the
strong base and butyl lithium to cause
an elimination reaction forming the
alkyne after treatment with water die
halides which may be formed by
halogenation of alkenes can be treated
with two equivalents of the strong base
sodium amide to form internal alkynes
this process can also be used to form
terminal alkynes however three
equivalents of the strong base are
required let's examine why by looking at
the mechanism the first molar equivalent
of sodium amédée protonates the molecule
and causes elimination of bromine
forming an intermediate alkyne the
second equivalent repeats this process
creating the alkyne terminal alkynes
have a pKa of about 24 which makes them
acidic enough to be deprotonated by
sodium amat the third equivalent
deprotonates the terminal h atom
creating an anion which is why water is
needed in both of the reactions that
form terminal alkynes the fact that all
kinds can be deprotonated with strong
base leads us to our first reaction of
alkynes a deprotonated alkyne or
acetylide anion can be alkylated with a
primary alkyl halide it is important
that the alkyl halide is primary the
acetylide ion is a strong base
so it can cause elimination if reacted
with hindered alkyl halides alkynes can
be reduced completely by hydrogenation
forming alkanes when a palladium
catalyst treated with lead salts called
lindlar catalyst is used in alkyne
hydrogenation the alkyne may be reduced
to the z alkyne the e alkyne can be
formed by treating the alkyne with
sodium in liquid ammonia this is a
radical reaction sodium transfers a
single electron to the alkyne forming a
radical anion this anion adopts the more
stable conformation putting the methyl
groups on opposite sides of the double
bond before it is protonated by ammonia
the mechanism here is abbreviated but
sodium donates another electron forming
a new anion which is again protonated by
ammonia like alkenes alkynes can add
halogens across multiple bonds
bromination or chlorination gives the
tetra halide here addition of BR two
across the bond occurs via of ammonium
ion halides can also be added using
hydrobromic or hydrochloric acid note
the regio selectivity - equivalence of
the halide are added to the more
substituted side of the alkyne we see
markovnikov addition the proton adds to
the less substituted carbon to form the
more stable carbo cation and the
addition occurs again in the same way to
the intermediate chloro alkyne terminal
alkynes can be converted to aldehydes or
ketones selectively with appropriate
reagent choice hydroboration oxidation a
two-stage process where the alkyne is
first treated with a boron reagent then
oxidized produces an aldehyde the boron
reagent adds to the least hindered side
the terminus
the alkyne the large boron reagent
prevents attack on the intermediate and
the oxidation step gives an enol which
to Tom arises to the more stable ketone
oxymercuration can be used to produce
ketones directly from alkynes the alkyne
reacts to form a mercurinium ion water
then attacks at the more substituted
carbon atom since the mercurinium ion
has carbo cation resonance and the
secondary carbo cation contributes more
to the overall structure than the
primary carbo cation again the enol
tautomer eise's to the ketone and
sulfuric acid protonates the carbonyl
this promotes elimination of mercury
forming another enol and a final two
Talmer ization gives the ketone
you